Is another way to avoid image files and
to keep your site responsive.
If you need to use a graphical
symbol like an arrow, a star or
a heart, check whether it's
available as a character
in a font you might be
surprised what's available.
When symbols and
icons are achieved using fonts,
they have all the response
of advantages of text.
They're infinitely scalable,
amenable to texts,
CSS effects, and
don't incur extra download.
The graphics on this page
are built without image files.
The body has a CSS gradient and
the star is just a text character
with a CSS shadow applied.
All responsibly sized.
The Unicode standard defines
the universal character set.
Over 100,000 characters
have been defined so far.
Some fonts support many
thousands of these.
Get to know your glyphs.